et bien nouveau si dr chiens destinés à
pallier les inconvénients de paris cet
engin s'appelle une vedette
radio taxi monsieur catherine ne vous
êtes le promoteur des vedettes
radio taxi avec un des engins donc plus
d'embarras plus d'encombrement puisqu'il
utilise une fois jusqu'à présent libre
c'est-à-dire la scène avec une douane et
radio taxi combien de temps mettra t on
par exemple pour aller de la place de la
concorde jusqu'à saint cloud environ 20
minutes
gags sérieusement du temps puisque avec
ce bateau auquel nous avons seulement
entendu une vitesse de 40 km alors que
sa vitesse est 62 nous avons mis environ
20 minutes pour venir de saint claud à
la place de la côte
pont de la concorde alors que le taxi
parti en même temps a mis 45 minutes à
un jour de
circulation normale je parle pas d'hier
bien sûr mais la vedette radio taxi et
peut-être un très bon système pour les
gens qui se rendent à deux endroits
différents mais tous les deux situés
près de la scène
mais si par exemple je suis dans le
centre de paris à l'opéra par exemple
comment fraîche pour l'utiliser si je
veux prendre néanmoins à la porte de
saint cloud nous avons pensé à cela
quelqu'un qui habite par exemple entre
saint claud je donne
les conditions la plus favorable nous
pourrions aller le chercher avec quatre
lots radiotoxiques nous apaiserait notre
centrale par téléphone nous allons le
chercher avec la radio taxi et ensuite
la vedette vient chercher au concept
loup et le transporte
plus possible de l'endroit où ils
désirent se rend si cet endroit est
assez éloigné nous pouvons leur prendre
la vedette est en relié par radio au
central nous pouvons leur prendre et
l'ordre
l'emmener au point où ils désirent
mais toutes les futures vedettes radio
taxis seront elles du même type que ce
bateau c'est à dire découvert et alors
quand il pleut non évidemment
celle ci se serait pour les gens qui
seraient vraiment pressés puisque c'est
un bateau assez rapide nous avons en
commander vedette
qui pourront transporter 6 à 8 personnes
à l'abri les jours de pluie et
à l'arrière du bateau les jours de beau
temps maintenant il faut parler du prix
de la course commencera-t-elle calculer
et à combien cela reviendra la course
évidemment tout est fonction étant donné
qu'actuellement la vitesse et de tous km
à leur part limités par les règlements
et que nous pensons fait un tarif basé
sur leur si nous ne faisons que douze
kilomètres à l'heure évidemment le prix
sera plus élevé que si nous obtenons de
marché à 40 à l'heure c'est très facile
à calculer
pouvez-vous néanmoins de donner un
exemple en comptant une vitesse moyenne
celle à laquelle vous désirez marcher
marcher environ à 40 à l'heure et
une course par exemple prendre cinq
jours la concorde devrait revenir à un
peu pas 15 100 francs quel que soit le
nombre de personnes vous parliez de
dérogation demandée pensez-vous obtenir
cette dérogation
nous l'espérons nous avons fait depuis
près d'un an des démarches auprès des
administrations compétentes
nous avons reçu un accueil favorable
auprès de monsieur le préfet de la seine
et monsieur
gaulliste il n'ya plus les services de
de la navigation et des travaux publics
qui 2
doit plus donner leur accord dernière
question alors quand peut-on espérer
naviguer sur la seine en vedette radio
taxi je pense que du jour où nous aurons
les autorisations
il faudra environ deux mois pour
implanter les infrastructures c'est à
dire les appontements que ce sont des
petits affrontements à des endroits
judicieusement choisis vous avez dit du
jour où nous aurons les autorisations
vous ne pouvez pas dire quand une idée
je suis vous pouvez le commander pour
apprendre à bien servir et bien nous le
demandons en ce moment et en ce moment
nous roulons doucement avec cette
vedette qui peut aller je crois très
rapidement des spas
[Musique]